- In 1986, the residents
of New High Street
in Headington, near Oxford,
woke up to find there was
a new addition to the road:
a shark in the roof of number two.
It was commissioned by
the owner of the house.
It's protest artwork, anti-war,
symbolic of bombs crashing
down into buildings.
And of course, English planning
laws do not allow someone
to suddenly install a
giant shark sculpture
in their roof
in a residential area.
At least, not without
consulting the neighbors first.
- So in 1986, my dad put a 25ft fiberglass and steel shark
through the roof of his house.
He'd just bought his first house
and the first night he moved in,
he heard planes going overhead,
he was sort of woken by this.
And in the morning
he read the newspaper
and, I suppose, saw destroyed houses
in Libya that had been bombed.
The story goes that my dad
and sculptor John Buckley
were sat, drinking, celebrating,
the purchase of this house,
sort of mulling over how to deal with
the shock of the bombing of Tripoli.
They were up for a fight,
and they did this shark
without planning permission, in secret.
There was this sort of mixed reaction.
A lot of people were shocked
and didn't quite know
what was going on.
I think some people thought
it might have been real
which is an eyeopener and
certainly funny looking back.
A lot of people just loved it
and thought it was brilliant,
right from the word go.
The council, obviously, were
very much "not here, thank you,
"and certainly not without
planning permission, this is outrageous".
- So the months and years
after the shark was installed
played out exactly as you would expect.
The council said take it down.
The owner said no. It went to court.
It took six years to resolve and the shark
was eventually allowed to stay
when a senior British
government official intervened
and said, "Yes, this has
enough artistic merit that,
"as a one off, it can stay."
And now it's an icon of the area,
known around the world,
and as far as I can tell,
generally liked by the folks around here.
Perhaps a bit more than the
current owner would like.
Before we get to that though,
I did have a couple
of more practical
questions about the shark.
Like: does it have a head?
- It doesn't have a head.
It's just a half bust of a
shark crashing through the roof.
I think they cut a crude
hole and dropped that in
with a crane initially,
and then sort of shored it up
as soon as they humanly could.
There was no preparation, obviously,
because that would've tipped people off.
It's fiberglass with steel reinforcement.
The steel struts on the inside connect out
through the ceiling and
down into the walls.
So it's structurally connected.
It's there to stay.
It needs repainting every now and then.
And there's just continual
checking to make sure
everything's in tiptop condition.
- This year, thanks for a nomination
from a presumably well-meaning
member of the public,
the shark was put on the
local list of heritage assets.
Now the shark isn't on the national list
of protected buildings yet.
It could still be taken down
without breaking the law,
but local registration
is often the first step
to being on the national list.
And owning a listed building
is a pretty significant burden.
The local government requires you
to keep it in good condition
and also keep it the same.
And if you don't, they can fix
it themselves and bill you.
Art, just like anything
else, requires upkeep.
And there are news stories that show that over the last few decades,
the shark, and this house, were
sometimes in extremely poor condition.
- Drop a shark through
the roof of your house,
there's some leakage problems that
one might immediately encounter!
It turns out it's very
difficult to repair those.
Until finally my mum ultimately stepped in
and did the whole thing up to, I think,
quite a nice standard.
Though I've been renting
it out as an Airbnb,
it's just a lovely place
and it means a lot to me
and I like that people can come and be
close to it and part of it too.
So someone put it forward for the
Oxford Asset Heritage Register.
On the council website, they say that
there's absolutely no restrictions placed.
This is just for their record keeping.
But they do mention that any
planning permission changes
will necessarily take
this into consideration.
I thought this was an
interesting take because, well,
nominally this is here
to preserve this shark
but this is controlled
through the planning laws.
And seems to me you can't
really preserve something
that's specifically
there to challenge that.
That seems to be completely absurd.
And to miss sort of the artistic point,
which is probably the thing
you would want to preserve,
if you're preserving a piece of art!
- As a bystander, I love art like this,
where part of the work
is how it interfaces
with the world and with bureaucracy.
But for the local officials
it must be frustrating
because they know that
anything they do to this shark
becomes part of the art,
part of the story.
List it, unlist it, demand its removal,
demand its preservation,
deliberately ignore it,
whatever they do, that's art now!
I wouldn't want to be in that position.
- So my dad passed away in 2019.
We spoke a little bit about
the listing just before he did.
He had sort of mixed feelings.
On the one hand, he had
been fighting
against the council for
a large portion of his life.
And on the other hand, he
had these considerations
about the legacy of the
place moving forward
and liked that they
were acknowledging him.
You've got this idea that
the council have come around
and changed their mind
and are now embracing
something they weren't before.
And on the other hand, you've got this,
I think, slightly more truthful side,
which is that these are
totally different councillors.
The councillors that hated it
are all gone.
And these new ones,
although they love it
are applying the same kind of control,
which again, flies in
the face of the piece.
I guess there's a bit of conflict there.
I wish he was still here to ask
and see how it all panned out.
I think he'd like that we're still
talking about it today, very much.
- For now, the shark is not
protected, not officially.
In a few years... who knows?